the commissioner of the metropolitan
police essentially said she used the
word abaddon that
wayne cousins was an exceptional
uh case a bad apple as it were a one-off
and that everybody else would be
appalled by his behavior
do you agree that he's just a one-off
good morning trevor first of all what i
would like to say is that the majority
of police officers are good caring
officers who are there for the right
reasons
wayne cousins was a monster in uniform
but unfortunately there is a culture
where he was allowed to flourish and the
whatsapp group that he was a part of and
other people are
is just one sign of that and i've heard
other comments about right across the
country about this sort of culture
existing i have experienced it and i
feel that it is time for all police
officers and all members of the public
to stand up and say enough is enough
you uh just said whatsapp groups are are
you aware that these kinds of whatsapp
groups
still exist amongst police officers
i am aware because i even spoke to one
of my colleagues yesterday and when
officers whether they're male or female
some of them are calling it out and when
they do call it out they are then denied
job opportunities contracts are not
extended and they are the ones who get
vilified
in my view what we should be doing and
i've talked about this before is there
should be a support bubble around
individuals who are strong enough and
brave enough to fight this
but it should go one step further
we should be actively encouraging people
to come forward and say this is not
right this is what's happening and let's
take action together but moving on from
that it's not just about police this is
a societal issue and when we talk about
deaths there are more deaths through
domestic violence than there is through
counterterrorism or knife crime yet we
have tasks for
forces we have units that deal with
those particular crimes how come we
don't have anything like that for
domestic violence how come we don't have
the same sort of money being spent on it
i'd like to come back to the the wider
set of issues in a moment but just
sticking with the police for the moment
is it your belief
that there could be
other wayne cousins
types of people currently wearing the
uniform carrying a warrant card and that
the current vetting procedures uh and
management procedures of the met and
other police forces
simply won't be picking them up
i have real serious concerns about the
vetting procedures this man not only got
through the vetting after indecency
offences in 2015 in 2018 he was taken in
the met he was then given a gun to carry
on the streets of london so that was
another form of vetting
i believe there are in other individuals
who have got questionable backgrounds
who should be being looked at
not just in the met right up and down
the country and i think we have missed
that and instead of looking backwards we
should be looking forward and making
sure that those individuals are targeted
now
do you think that that means that
to understand how to target them that
there should be an
independent inquiry into the vetting
procedures
there should be an independent inquiry
but in addition to that everybody who
works in policing now should be
re-vetted those people who have got
through the vetting procedure 20 years
ago 30 years ago all of them
every single person needs to be reviewed
and if anything comes up in their past
and it doesn't have to be a conviction
it just needs to be come to notice
because this man did come to notice so
every person should be re-vetted and
re-assessed as to whether or not they
are safe to be working with members of
the community and members of the public
to be clear every every police officer
should go through the vetting procedure
once more
is that
as a one-off or do you think that's
something that should be done
periodically every few years
it needs to be done now as an urgent
measure to reassure the public and
rebuild the trust and confidence that
policing has lost but it needs to be
done on a regular basis so that we don't
have anybody who can even come close to
the actions of wayne cousins we need to
make sure that we restore that trust and
confidence and in my view you know i've
heard the your previous guests who've
spoken about
the next steps and the commissioner has
reassured them that she's going to take
action
well i haven't actually seen the
commissioner standing in front of a
camera saying i'm sorry and now i want
to listen to you i've heard her say
sorry but i haven't heard her say i now
want your views i want to set up a focus
group an urgent task group i've heard
the um
houses of parliament were also guarded
by wayne cousins and there's going to be
an urgent review and inquiry into that
and there's going to be a conversation
with the commissioner but what about
normal people what about the normal
people who are walking around the
streets of london who's talking to them
who's listening to them
and i accept that the contract the
commissioner's contract has been
extended by two years well let's make it
a positive two years
why you know from now
the commissioner has got two years to
turn this around she needs to be taking
immediate action and
gone
you think she's the wrong you think
she's the wrong person to do this job
don't you
i it doesn't matter what i think the
decisions have been made so we have to
live with that but now it's about making
that positive difference going forward
and over the weekend scottish police
have decided that if a loan officer
stops a female they're going to put
their radios on loudspeakers so they can
speak to the control room how come we're
not we're not hearing that from the met
all we've heard is flag down a bus
well that's okay that's fine for the
first day for the first 24 hours but
we're not in the first 24 hours now but
the commissioner and the top team have
had time to think about what's the next
steps
okay can i return to the wider point
that i think you wanted to make which is
about the culture and
this is not just a question i think
applies to the police but pretty much to
every workplace but you can tell us uh
something about this
how is it that you think
that wayne cousins with all the points
that you've made about him being
identified
people knowing he'd exposed himself and
all that
how is it that nobody said anything
trevor i wish i knew the answer to that
question and i would be surprised if no
one did say anything i think that in the
coming days and weeks we may find that
individuals did raise issues but they
were just not acted on because there
isn't that
support there isn't that strength of
feeling to take matters further and in a
lot of cases the canteen culture is such
that oh she couldn't take a joke it was
just banter it meant nothing and i i
wouldn't be surprised if in the next few
weeks we find that people had did raise
these issues